see how you see that kind of charcoal in
the cake
it's just that little
i'm assuming you're offering
mr kent
he said you'd come
now let's hope you're not too late
the bells already been wrong
and they've heard it
but in the dark among the stars
the god is dead
happy comic-con week everyone this is
going to be my new justice league snyder
cut video zack snyder just dropped
another teaser for the movie so we'll
break it down
there's a bunch of easter eggs in a
bunch of stuff during the justice league
snyder cut panel that he revealed about
the movie
there's gonna be a bunch more comic con
trailers this week so be sure to
subscribe to get all those videos we'll
do a new amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want to see in
the snyder cut
if you're not sure where this came from
there was a special convention called
justice khan organized by a bunch of
fans this week
they did this special zack snyder panel
because the in real life comic con got
cancelled because of the virus
so just starting with the footage first
you may have seen a version of this
deleted scene like i sort of cobbled it
together there's a version with superman
in the black
suit like that's obviously what he meant
to show off this is what he's going to
look like
in the actual black suit but he actually
said that what happened is
is the version that you see with him in
the red blue suit is something that they
did
after the movie had been released
theatrically they just had a bunch of
snyder footage that they hadn't released
yet they said okay why don't we just
polish this and post it online
so that's how this full version of the
scene wound up online a couple years ago
this has been around for a while
but obviously the black suit version of
this meeting is the one that we'll see
during the snyder cut
the scene itself actually happens later
in the movie it's after superman has
fully come back to his senses and the
reason why he's wearing the black suit
is one zack snyder said because his red
blue suit had been destroyed in batman v
superman there was that giant spike
through it so he made a bunch of jokes
about the red blue suit during the
theatrical cut like well hey it's a
kryptonian suit maybe it can repair
itself you know kryptonian technology
you also probably remember this other
deleted scene with superman actually
going to his fortress of solitude the
kryptonian ship to get the black suit
where you see the warframe suit you also
see a couple other suits in here
but he says the main reason why he's
wearing the black suit is because that's
the first one he would pick when he came
back
but also practically because that red
blue suit had been destroyed
even though it wasn't a big surprise he
did say that he actually had to fight
the studio to get the black
suit in the movie so when they filmed it
they had to film it really special so
that they could tune the suit to be more
black in post-production
hoping that he would eventually convince
the studio to let him use the black suit
so when he comes to see alfred here this
is when the rest of the team
batman wonder woman cyborg aquaman have
already gone to fight steppenwolf so
superman is going to join them but he's
coming to see alfred to find out what's
going on first
while they were playing this a lot of
people were also asking about green
lantern and about martian manhunter so
zack snyder did talk a lot about them in
the movie
without giving away really big spoilers
but he did confirm a couple things
he did confirm that there is a version
of green lantern during the movie
there's a couple scenes that we know
about from the original snyder cut he
also talked about the origin of the
snyder cut too
he said right now what they're doing is
they're restoring his assembly cut
like he says in this tweet here the
assembly cut was originally five hours
long
that was completed in february of 2017
that super long version of the cut so
there weren't many special effects that
had been finished yet there was a lot of
green screen
a lot of cyborg walking around in his
pajamas then as he was cutting it down
he was forced to leave the movie under
those
unfortunate circumstances joss whedon
came on and they did the theatrical cut
so what he did is is when they green lit
the actual snyder cut and started giving
him money to work on it he just went
back to that original
five hour assembly cut and they're
working from that version of the movie
when it actually comes to green lantern
though it does sound like there's a
version of hal jordan during the movie
we don't know exactly what he'll be
doing during the snyder cut
because the actual green lantern scenes
that we know about don't involve hal
jordan himself as green lantern they're
actually other versions of green
lanterns
there are a couple claims about what's
happening in the dark side flashback
scene he also talked a little bit about
darkseid during the movie too so i'll
explain that in a second
but there's some conflicting reports
that jalan gur who's the green lantern
in the theatrical cut
wasn't actually something that zack
snyder did and there were other green
lantern things happening during this
scene
yalen gur was just one of the original
green lanterns from a couple thousand
years ago in the space sector that earth
belongs to
but in present day the actual big green
lantern scene was supposed to be one of
the original post credit scenes where
two green lanterns kilawog in tomar ray
show up to batman at his lakeside house
here presumably they were going to talk
to him about the threat of darkseid and
that was going to push them into more
cosmic story during the second justice
league film that was still when they
were doing
two justice league films so there wasn't
supposed to be a ton
of green lantern corps during the first
movie but some green lantern corps
and way more during the second movie and
that was going to sort of spin them
up into the green lantern corps movie
that would have happened after justice
league 2.
no joke if you remember the original
schedule there was supposed to be a
green lantern corps movie that they
released in 2020
but that was before they made all those
big changes to the dc movie roster
because zack snyder is the person that
cast gal gadot is wonder woman who then
went on to become wonder woman in the
wonder woman solo movie wonder woman
my assumption is that the hal jordan
that zack snyder would have cast for one
of the justice league movies
would have gone on to be the hal jordan
of the full-blown green lantern corps
spin-off movie
they're still planning on making a green
lantern core movie but obviously it's
going to be a different actor now
a lot of people have asked what's going
to happen going forward with the snyder
cut
if it's successful i don't think it's
going to change a lot about their future
movie plans
i think they'll just release more
extended cuts of movies they'll be more
open to doing stuff like that on hbo max
the way zack snyder talked about it
recently is he said he views the snyder
cut itself as sort of the self-contained
universe like the snyder verse is what
he called it
his films including man of steel batman
v superman and now the justice league
snyder cut
sort of standing on their own in their
own little bubble of the dc movies
i know i also mentioned martian
manhunter during the panel zack snyder
also talked a little bit about harry
lennox's version of martian manhunter so
a while ago he posted on vero
all these storyboards of him becoming
martian manhunter
i don't know if it started out that way
in man of steel if he always intended
for him to become a version of that
character
it might have started out as a fan thing
that then he incorporated into future
movies and was going to pay off during
justice league
but during the panel when people were
talking about him posting this martian
manhunter harry lennox stuff
he didn't deny anything he just said yep
yep martian manhunter shaking his head
so i just take that as sort of a subtle
confirmation that we'll find some sort
of reveal
during the justice league snyder cut i
don't know if that means full-blown
martian manhunter on screen
or vicious harry lennox himself speaking
to the justice league characters
revealing himself as another alien from
outer space
i think the whole idea with the snyder
cut is that they were going to tease
more cosmic stories they were going to
get way bigger with the dc universe
because you were heading into dark side
new gods territory they are making a new
gods movie but it's a completely
different group of people that's making
that
so whoever their version of dark side is
going to be their version of the new
gods they'll be different from the stuff
that we see during the snyder cut
he talked a little bit about his version
of steppenwolf just being way scarier
way more hardcore
and badass if you remember the deleted
scene of batman v superman with lex
luthor inside the kryptonian ship
learning about steppenwolf the mother
boxes this is basically what steppenwolf
looks like and this is actually better
concept art too it gives you a better
idea
he also made some jokes about darkseid
so obviously he released that other
teaser trailer with wonder woman in the
dark side flashback scene
during that scene he's actually ooxas he
hasn't become darkside yet he hasn't
taken that name
the reason why he needs to use a weapon
is because he doesn't have the omega
force he doesn't have his omega beams
his traditional power that you see in
all the other movies that he appears
during
zack snyder made a bunch of jokes about
how hard it was to pronounce some of the
names because there's no real guide in
the comics and not wanting to get it
wrong
so for that very funny reason he said
that he made sure that none of the
characters ever actually
say that name out loud usually when
they're talking about darkseid they just
talk about darkseid
like when wonder woman is looking at
this picture here you actually see his
name written in greek
dark side he said that they don't
actually have the final title but the
idea is to call it zack snyder's justice
league but apparently there are actually
some really big illegal issues with what
they actually call the movie
the other really surprising thing was
when he was talking about the format
and how it's going to look physically
different from the theatrical cut
so he broke out this aspect ratio
explainer using a drawing that he did
himself of ben affleck's batman
to explain how much extra footage you
have in that true imax format
so he said that the justice league
snyder cut was originally filmed in that
imax aspect ratio so the theatrical cut
that we saw even the footage they
included that was zack snyder's footage
was all cropped the other reference that
he made was that teaser trailer that he
released a little while ago of the
wonder woman dark side scene
so you have to imagine the whole movie
looking like this but there's so much
extra visual information at the tops and
bottoms of the frames
if there's any other clips or any
footage that he drops before then of
course i'll do videos about it but
everyone just post all of your reactions
in the comments below
and let me know what other things you're
hoping to see in the snyder cut
but for those of you asking it will be a
completely different movie completely
different story so it's not like them
just making a longer version of the
theatrical cut it'll be totally
different
while you wait for everything click here
for all my other justice league snyder
cut trailers and click here for all my
other comic-con trailer videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]